you you do not have children yourself
but you are an
uncle and i look at you and i think
that's a guy who'd be a fun uncle are
you a fun uncle
yeah i'm i think i am a fun uncle i mean
uh
owen's got two great little boys who are
i think five and eight and my brother
andrew has a ten year old daughter and i
i get along great with them uh yeah
really fun kids i mean during this
pandemic i mean i did it is a little
like the shining at times i did have
kind of a shining type moment with
owen's son ford where i was saying
you know i love you don't you ford
you're good boy
it got real it got real weird didn't it
um what's your dad been saying about me
lately you can tell me for it
don't worry about it no i get along
great with those guys they're they're
great little kids
and um yeah definitely the kind that um
make me want to have some kids of my own
which i
i i should get on sooner rather than
later
i'd put it off for a while if i were you
yeah put it off i mean
anthony quinn you know he had a child
when he was 80.
i just don't want to be one of those
dads that has to pay somebody in the
in the neighborhood to throw the
football with this kid
which i feel like i see here and there
in l.a yeah
i'm at that stage but i just did it out
of laziness uh i just yeah
i wanted a really tight spiral so i i
hired someone who knew what they were
doing